we are delighted to bring you this
seminar presented by
lab roots welcome everyone thank you for
joining us
for today's keynote presentation titled
complexities of characterizing mineral
particle
at the pulmonary interface it's my
pleasure to introduce you to
dr christopher weiss toxicology liaison
and senior advisor
officer of the director of national
institutes of health
national institutes of environmental
health science
and national toxicology program
for complete biography of our speaker
please visit the
tab at the top of your screen if you
have any questions that arise during the
presentation
we encourage you to submit them in the q
and a box
our speaker will address those questions
following his presentation
as a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits click on the
continuing education credits tab
located at the top right corner of your
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain those
credits
please join me now in welcoming dr
christopher
weiss i will now turn the presentation
over to him
welcome sir
and getting used to being ensconced
in our respective uh isolation
areas i'm here at home
joining from the washington dc area and
i'm happy to be here
i am going to go ahead and start my uh
my presentation and i expect everyone
can see that now i hope
uh i've already had an introduction but
we'll just
skip through this slide this is our
facility in north carolina actually i'm
stationed in the washington dc area but
we have a large laboratory in the
research triangle park area of north
carolina and that's a view of the
facility and another view
we are part of the national
institutes of health there are 27
institutes of health
you may have heard of the national
library of medicine
the national institute of allergy and
infectious disease work
uh and i uh that that institute is
getting
lots of uh attention right now as dr
anthony fauci uh is the director of that
institute and has been advising on the
corona virus issues
uh you've if you've been watching the
news you've probably seen his
face uh he works in the same building
that i work in
and uh we're here on the bethesda campus
at in
uh at nih
uh what i'd like to do with with you
today for you today
is to give you an overview of uh
uh an incident that is both modern and
has been going on for decades
it's a forensic problem that's quite
complex
there's lots of controversy and
disagreement about it right now
it's really a story of
corporate uh greed really corporate
the uh the interest in uh
businesses making money and putting that
those interests
sometimes some businesses not all
certainly putting those interests
ahead of public health
so we're going to overview some of the
contemporary debates and controversies
and i
invite you to follow those they're in
the news regularly these days
and then i'm going to not address those
contemporary issues specifically because
i'm a little close
a little too closely involved in those
excuse me
but um i'm going to there's a
there's a similar incident that occurred
almost 20 years ago now
that's strikingly uh uh
uh similar to the the incident that's
going on today and i'd like to share
that with you
uh and then um check back in on the
status of what's going on today with
with those same controversies so
you may have seen uh photographs like
this in the new york times
uh you there's an interesting article
in chemical watch just a couple of weeks
ago
that came out and chem watch uh has been
following this story quite closely
in a way that's it's technical
forensically technical
the new york times is discussing the
story
in light of various cosmetic products
that we know are causing serious
poisonings
and deaths so i'm not again i'm not
going to talk in any specific detail
about
that present controversy but we'll want
to walk through
walk you through an incident that
occurred almost 20 years ago that i was
very involved with
uh that's very very similar to what's
going on now
this is a map of montana obviously
and i'm going to talk about an area in
the far west northwest
corner of montana one of the most remote
areas in the lower
48 states excuse me
and uh it's about uh 100
miles west of glacier national park so
if you've ever
been to glacier park excuse me if you've
ever been to glacier park
uh you know how remote it is in in that
area of
our country uh
so once again um uh this is
this area the brown on the map here is
the panhandle of idaho and libby montana
is a little town of about 5000 people
just a few miles south of the canadian
border and a few miles east
of the idaho border
it's a very vibrant but
but small village here's a picture of
libby montana
it's a beautiful beautiful area of the
country it's nestled in the kootenay
valley that's the kootenai river that
you see coursing through
libby montana excuse me i got a frog in
my throat here
and there's a there's a movie if you've
ever seen a movie it's a
bit of an old movie now called the river
wild and that
movie will give you beautiful views of
the kootenai river
in this remote area of our country
the valley the kootenai valley and libby
montana's nestled in between the cabinet
mount cabinet mountains in
in almost in mid-summer it's far enough
north and they're tall enough to have
snow caps all year round
so in november of 1999
i was working to provide scientific
support for the federal government
forensic scientific support for major
incidents and disasters that occurred in
our in our country
and uh it was a an exciting
and very busy job and and
in in november just a few days before
thanksgiving in 1999
uh this article came out in the seattle
post intelligencer
and what it reported this uh this uh
reporter dr er andrew schneider
uh reported that in this small town of
five thousand people there were several
hundred
former miners wives and children
that had been exposed and either died or
been diagnosed with fatal illness
in this small town so we were
immediately deployed
my my science team and an on-scene
coordinator
were immediately deployed to this area
to
help washington d.c understand what was
going on
and so um this is a this is a
a picture of libby looking down the main
street of libby
it's i want i want you to notice the
inversion the clouds that are laying low
in there that that's part
of what cause problem that i'm gonna
describe to you over the next
over the next few minutes
so as part as initial part of our
investigation
we traveled to an area where we were
advised was the source of the problem
that was going on in libby and it was an
abandoned not an abandoned mine but a
mine that had been closed
just a couple of years earlier that was
about five to six miles outside of
outside of libby montana and this is a
picture that i took of that mine
on my first visit there uh just uh uh
probably a day before thanksgiving in
1999.
again you can see it's quite high in the
in the cabinet mountains
and it's been somewhat closed but still
lots of evidence of mining this is a
picture of that mine
when it was fully operational and the
way they mined was
a strip strip mining process where they
basically used dynamite and large
equipment
to make these terraces and and
tear uh a particular type of mineral
out of the out of the mountain and for
scale here
there's a i don't know if you can see it
on your screen but there's a
there's a very large piece of mining
equipment
way in the bottom of that pit gives you
an idea of how how big that
that hole is this was an area of the
mind that they called the glory hole
because it produced the type of material
that they were
they were looking for in this mine so
this is what what they were looking for
this is the ore that they were pulling
out of the mine
and had i known what is holding in my
hand when i took this photograph
i never uh i never would have done it
uh this is the material that it turns
out
was uh just a deadly uh
exposure material to the to the people
in libby um what you're looking at here
is it is the dark in in the in the ore
that i'm holding in my hand
is a type of hydrobiotic uh it's a
it's a silicaceous mineral the white
mineral
is a very fibrous type of uh
rock it's it breaks into small fibers
and uh it you know we initially expected
that
it would it was asbestos
so what the miners did from about
1960 about 1960 63
until the mid 90s was they would
strip mine this material out of the out
of the
mountain a mountain called zono light
mountain
and they would bring it to this mill
also on the mountain they would crush it
up
with ball mills and uh various
means and they would blow air hot air
through it
through the material to remove that
white material from the hydro biotite
that they were really after
so what looks like smoke coming out of
this mill
is not really smoke but it's uh
fight the fibrous material that's been
crushed away from the rock and is now
um uh being
on the problem that they were having
exacerbated by the types of inversions
that i showed you on the previous slide
was that the mine and this picture was
taken from where that mill
had been it had been torn down by the
time we got there
in 1999 but uh
this picture was taken from the area
where the mill had been down
into libby so you can see that although
libby's about five miles away
that material and that dust was making
its way into the air shed
throughout the kootenai valley
this is uh this is my friend les
grampstead
les passed away about six years ago
due to inhalation of the material that
we're going to talk over the next few
minutes and here les
has in in protest uh and
and begging for help and action has
put crosses for all his fan members his
co-workers and his neighbors who had
died
from uh exposure to to this material
and les promised me before he before he
passed away i got to know
not just last but many people in this
town after after working there on
on the case for almost two years
every every single week
uh les pro made me promise
that i would share his experience and
the experience of others
uh with with you with anyone that i
could
find who would listen to him and so on
the next slide we have
a short video it's about three and a
half minutes long
that i'd like to play to you and it
includes
les's perspective on his experience
in the montana as well as the experience
of several others
one of one of whom is was the manager
of the mine who you will see in in
legal deposition during this short clip
so
let's go ahead and play that
[Music]
my first experience there was what in
the
hell did i get myself into
i just couldn't believe that the dust
and
[Music]
the dirt
i went into the construction room
because that's where i was told to
report and he told me i was going to be
a sweeper and a dry mill and i had no
idea what he was talking about
but first you go over to the warehouse
and
get a respirator i had this respirator
on in about
15 minutes i couldn't breathe so i
pulled this respirator off and it was
just plugged
solid i thought boy i'm not getting
nothing done and if i don't
i'm going to get canned so i just pulled
the respirator off and let it
dangle around my neck here and i and i
really went to work and
at noon i went back down to
eat lunch and i i was just covered with
this stuff
everywhere and uh tom deschazer was
sitting in there and he was the foreman
of the
of the construction department and he
said how do you like that
dust and i said jesus that's the worst i
ever seen i can't
i can't imagine anything like it
like it's the worst i've ever seen and
jeez they all laughed you know and
slapped her leg and
said ah it's just a nuisance thus you'll
get used to it
the stuff was in your clothes it was
everywhere
it was so fine the only way you knew it
is
you brought a cup of coffee and you
looked down
you could see it settling in the top of
your coffee but you couldn't see it in
the air but you could see it sibling
in your coffee
[Music]
you couldn't get it off of me really
it's just stuck
same way with the ore you know and so i
took it home with me and
and i'd walk in the house you know then
my oldest daughter and my oldest son
they'd grab me by the legs you know
because they was happy to see me and
hearing coming to rita you know and
she'd come over you know and we'd have a
hug and
christ that was covered with this stuff
you know it wasn't that i was being
sloppy it was just that i couldn't get
it off
is it correct from that from 1948 on you
knew
and the company always knew that there
was a serious health problem because of
the large amount of dust
concentrated there
[Music]
it was certainly known that in some
areas there were large concentrations of
dust
and it's certainly common knowledge that
too much dust of any kind is is
not a healthy situation
grace was on the school board grace was
on the hospital board
grace on the bank and when you talked
about
dust control here at anything about the
dust and
and what it was doing harmful to these
people here
the first thing come out of their mouth
was you you're going to close that mine
down and you're going to put all these
people out of work
you didn't have very many friends when
you start talking like that so
uh that video had a couple of things i
would like to share
share with you uh and point out
um the uh
the workers were obviously talking about
occupational exposures that were
occurring up on the mind but there are
also
tremendously high exposures lethal
exposures throughout the
valley the kootenai valley and
throughout the village of
of libya montana and it's
it continues to be a bit of a problem uh
what they
what they were mining what they were
after as i mentioned was a type of
hydrobiotic it's a silicacious mineral
that when uh that when you mine it it's
it's flat
and and looks like micah if you've ever
seen micah
and uh it it
um uh if you heat it to about 600
degrees it pops like popcorn and so what
you see here is this expanded material
that is is popcorn-like in nature
here's another couple of views of it it
was it was sorted into different sizes
and marketed for a wide variety of
products just a tremendously wide
variety of products and i'll show you
some of
what those were you may have seen this
material in in
potting soil see the white flakes in the
potting soil in the upper left
it's commonly used to ship
breakable containers particularly for
laboratory situations if you
if you're one of those folks that work
in a laboratory and you order solvents
it might come
in vermiculite so that's that's what
this looks like in packing material
it was also used particularly around the
processing facilities and i'll show you
that the material was actually shipped
from libby montana throughout the united
states to various processing
facilities that would expand it by
heating it and then market it it was
easier to ship
and it's in its uh unexpanded form so it
was shipped all over the country
and it was used uh especially it near
and around these processing plants as as
garden
material was used for playground
material
it was used for paving roads etc
this is a this is a photograph taken
from one of those
uh uh an abandoned processing facility
in uh minneapolis minnesota
so this the material that these children
are playing in
is waste material from the
expanding and processing of this ore
this map
shows areas where the large circ the
larger circles
are areas where the material was
actually shipped by train from libby
montana
to processing facilities throughout the
united states
the smaller the smaller circles
are areas where the material was
distributed so they're distributors
uh as i said you can still buy this
material in uh
large uh um big box stores such as
i won't name any specifically but any of
the large
garden stores etc us sell this material
there is an effort to keep it cleaner
than it than it was
in libby but uh mineralogists will tell
you that almost all vermiculite has this
type of fiber in it that we'll describe
it was also used shockingly
to insulate as many as 35 million homes
throughout the united states and canada
so this is what it looks like you may
you may want to peek in your attic and
see if you have this type of material in
your attic
uh if you do there are some some steps
you can take
to to eliminate your exposure
or or at least reduce your exposure to
the material
this is an individual in colorado
springs colorado who
is now deceased but he and his son
had insulated their attic with this
material
in in one summer in colorado that was
the only exposure that they had was
uh just the insulation of their attic at
one time
and uh both both of those individuals
had passed away from lung disease
uh the material was also used to make
popcorn ceilings you see in the left
two panels on the left that
uh this material was used both
as an insulation and as an artful kind
of decoration in this large atrium you
see at the
lower left lower left panel during
during our investigation of course we
were looking into
various records and and paperwork that
that the company had
as part of our as part of the case we
were building
and we were um we learned during that
time
again this was probably about 2000
we learned that
the world trade center had been
insulated using this material as a
fireproofing on
the lower parts of both both of the
buildings
and of course during our investigation
the world trade center was hit with uh
uh the terrorist attack and both of the
towers collapsed
uh this was horrific to us because
we we knew that not only was there a
tremendous amount of
other materials in those buildings but
they were also
aligned with this insulation
material that would have been spread
throughout
the the lower manhattan area
so again what you know what is this
stuff what we knew
that we had been told by the industry by
wr grace and wr grace scientists and
their contractors
that this material was not asbestos that
there was no asbestos that the mine had
been closed and there was no
no risk any longer because there was no
there was no no ongoing exposure we
wanted to look into that much more
deeply and we
initiated a a a large investigation
that included uh you know both records
investigation
exposure monitoring throughout the town
uh
and um uh you know
an effort to characterize this material
the problem that we were having
is that we knew that
uh regulated asbestos is is
only a very very small part of the
mineral fibers of elongate
mineral particles that cause exposure
and we
we suspected certainly that this was the
case in libby
we were told that the material on the
mine was not
a type of regulated asbestos and here
are the six
types of regulated vessels asbestos this
is still true today
uh the crystal there are two types two
main types a serpentine
or snake-like asbestos called chrysotel
this is about
makes up more than 90 of the asbestos
that was used in most products
throughout our country and um there's an
amphibole type of asbestos this is made
up of many
different forms of minerals and uh i
have uh
there's five of them listed here these
are the only
five that are regulated and we we
suspected that some of these materials
the actinolite tremolite
might be present in libby but we had to
had to
prove that forensically so we initiated
a major
uh and exposure science based
investigation in libby montana that
proceeded under emergency response
authorities of the federal government
for the next two years from 99
on on into 2021
and you know we started by figuring
trying to determine the best way to trap
this material
we used asbestos cowls and look very
carefully at the difference between
cellulose fiber and nucleopore uh
material as a as a means to to trap them
the uh fibers that that were in the air
and we used uh we had
more than a dozen electron microscope
laboratories
on um on contract in order to help us
measure every aspect of the environment
in libby
so um what what this
uh series of uh micrographs show
is the uh
the this the flake in the upper
left-hand panel
is a flake of this hydrobiotic
and if you look at it at low
magnification so that upper left-hand
panel
is just a 12 times magnification uh
through
like a binocular microscope you don't
see
much you don't see a whole lot of fiber
if you move then
in the direction of the arrow down to
the lower left panel
you begin to see small particulates and
what we're doing here is just zooming in
on that same flake of hydrobiotic
and then so you begin to see little
particulates if you go to
a scanning electron microscope at 2 000
times magnification you begin to clearly
see these thin needle-like structures
that are the elongate mineral particles
that we were interested in
and then if you go to ten thousand
magnification in the lower right you
you see that these things are um
are our mineral and they're
very long and thin
we use the electron microscope this is a
genie ore
in her laboratory in denver one of the
laboratories that we had under contract
electron microscopes most electron
microscopes have the ability to
shine a one micron
beam of high energy gamma radiation at a
particle in the view scope
and in doing so you get a spectrum
like this because the gamma radiation
excites the inner shell electrons in the
material you're
you're bombarding with that that gamma
beam
and when those electrons relax they give
off a signal the frequency of the signal
along the x-axis is an indication of the
atom that you're looking at
and the magnitude along the along the
y-axis
is a measure of how much of that of
those atoms are present
so by doing so you can identify
fingerprints
of the minerals that are are that you're
looking at
under the microscope so you just target
that beam at a particular mineral and
and take a look at it so we did that for
thousands
tens of thousands of samples uh in libby
they're still making such measurements
in libby today 20 years later
but um we we did it often enough to get
a statistical
idea of the type of minerals we were
looking at and
sure enough the mineral that most of the
minerals that we were looking at were
not
were not
among the regulated asbestos minerals so
you see
across the top edenite and richterite
going down into the blue panel winchite
and magnesio are benzonite none of these
minerals were part of the regulated
material and we were we were concerned
that we would not be
able to regulate this material at all
using
the existing laws on the on the books
so um
let's click here
uh but what we did see is down in the
lower left
that there was the presence although
not much of tremolite and actinilite
so we turned to to that
return to using that information
to uh begin
uh uh
regulating and zoning in on charges that
that we thought might be brought against
wr grays and this slide
shows uh a bundle
of these fibers we saw this often in the
samples that we were collecting
this is a bundle of those fibers and you
can see that
they're they're they're clearly
associated with each other but stepping
on them
grinding them uh releasing them
would certainly cause a
these fibers to be spread out and move
into the environment
at the same time we were doing this the
industry
funded several researchers to
argue the opposite opposition that these
materials
were not asbestos at all
they were they did not have
characteristics of asbestos they had
characteristics of cleavage fragments
and
uh they argued that cleavage fragments
are technically not
asbestos and therefore we could not
regulate them
so this was this was problematic for us
we
uh we knew that whether they were
cleavage fragments or asbestos this was
the material that was
causing health problems in and deaths in
libby
and so it became uh an interesting and
protracted argument that
in fact continues today in order to
prove our case we
felt that we had to measure uh health
effects
in the population so as part of our
investigation
we built a medical facility a
radiological testing
facility and we we recommended to the
entire population of libby that they be
screened
through this radiology unit this is
basically a triple wide trailer
that you're looking at that we built in
libby in order to affect
a large epidemiological study there by
screening
voluntarily screening the participants
we did get 7 000
individuals both present residents of
libby and those who had moved out of
town
to join us this is dr brad black he was
the
public health physician at the time and
here he is inside the clinic and
uh showing you a radiographic of of
lungs of the one of the one of the
residents of libby
so this is the type of uh disease that
we were seeing
in the population so the two panels on
the left are
microscope slides taken at autopsy
and you can see if you if you look
closely you see
the the mineral fiber the elongate
mineral particle
surrounded by cells that we'll we'll see
in a minute are macrophage
cells and both of those both of those
slides on the left are microscope slides
light microscope slides
showing what are called mineral bodies
or
pharyngenous bodies they're called
pharyngenous bodies because they collect
iron-based stain when they're stained on
the right
you can see this individual with um
with pleural plaques bilateral
pleural plaques in in their lung those
plaques at
autopsy what we're looking at at the
lower right are
the the plaques on the lower on the on
the diaphragmatic side of
the lungs of an individual who passed
away from
uh exposure in in libby montana
again here are the here are the types of
disease that we're seeing this is a
high-resolution cat scan
showing this unusual type of disease
that we saw in livy
pleural thickening and i say it was
unusual plural thickening is not
uncommon but the aggressiveness of this
particular
disease was striking and those little
spots where the arrows point are
form plaques beginning to form on this
individual's lung
they will grow rapidly and and
ultimately in case this individual's
lung
in such a way that they can no longer
breathe
there are some enhanced tools
to look at this type of disease this
individual happens to have been exposed
to elongate mineral particles a very
similar problem to what we saw in libby
but in this case these are uh folks
exposed to elongate mineral part
particles associated with uh tachonite
dust tachynite that is a very low grade
of iron ore that's mined in the upper
part of minnesota
and michigan so
the the lung diseases that we were
seeing and
um are still seeing that are
related to exposure to elongate mineral
particles are pleural effusions
pleural plaques and diffuse pleural
thickening pulmonary fibrosis
malignant mesothelioma which is a
classic
disease very deadly cancer associated
with exposure to asbestos
and all kinds of bronchiogenic
carcinomas so
um these were we saw
these diseases all these diseases in
libby and
we began uh arguing that in fact
there was there was a problem here with
exposure to these
uh related asbestos-related elongate
mineral particles
regardless of what the uh industry had
been telling us
so um the department of justice agreed
with us
so on february 7 2005 years after we
were
involved in the libya case and had won
a large civil suit against the um
the industry they the department of
justice filed criminal charges so
the several of the senior individuals
associated with the industry wr grace
were charged with fraud and obstruction
of justice
and and knowing endangerment in in libby
so this um
this really was the culmination of a lot
of
work done by the emergency response
group but i want to talk now
about the um you know what
what are these things and what is the
mechanism by which these elongate
mineral particles
are causing disease
and and right now the regulations are
based upon
characteristics that were very
useful years and years ago decades ago
when light micro microscopes were the
main tool
used for protecting people from asbestos
that's no longer the case
anymore we typically use scanning
electron micro
microscopes and transmission electron
microscopes for characterizing asbestos
so i want to take you on a
a little trip into the lung to see what
it what is it how do these things cause
disease and what are some of the
arguments that are going on right
now in in as we continue to
try to protect the public health from
exposure to elongate mineral particles
so let's just take a little trip into
the lung here you can see
that one of the things about these
mineral particles
are that they can off they align with
the laminar flow as we inhale
and they can make their way very very
deep into the lungs
as uh as we breathe
uh so we're gonna go we're gonna go
we're gonna dive deeply into the lung
now so
this is these are the alveoli of the
lung where gas exchange takes place
and you can see that as as we know there
are
venules and arterioles that course
throughout this lower part of the lung
that there's
also lymphatic tissue where the
particles small particles uh spherical
particles that make their way all the
way to this part of the lung
can be uh removed and excreted in the
urine
so let's go into one of these alveolar
sacs
and take a look at what they what they
what they are this is a scanning
electron microscope of
of those grape-like structures the
alveolar
the alveolar sacs that
where air exchange takes place
uh this is a cartoon of one of those
sacks and i just want to point out here
a couple of things the um the alveolar
capillary membrane is just
0.2 microns thick so really we're
this is this is uh there's almost
nothing between
uh our blood our blood stream in the
lung
and these uh
and and the air that comes into these
alveolar sacs
the other thing i want to point out in
the lower right is the
alveolar macrophage and i want to talk
to you a little bit about that
and the role that it plays in this type
of disease
so this is a scanning electron micro
micrograph of an
alveolar macrophage and this is one of
the things i love about biology because
it's just fascinating what these
these cells do there are trillions of
them throughout our body and and um
and of course throughout the lung where
they where they scavenge they move
they uh have an amoeba-like movement
they move throughout the uh the lung
they
identify using these pseudopods the
strings that look like they're coming
out of that cell
are actually pseudopods and if you look
closely you can see little sensory
ends on those pseudopods in this case
the
macrophage is looking for and
identifying bacteria
it will take those bacteria into itself
and digest those using
various types of lysosomal activities
and
these cells also identify aging
red blood cells which you see a red
blood cell up
up to the right and the macrophages is
uh
identifying that as a potential um
uh if if that blood cell is aberrant in
any way or it's aging that
it will be recycled the components of it
will be saved and other parts excreted
in the urine
so what happens if we look at the
left-hand side of this
is the macrophage uh and this is
obviously a cartoon
of a mac uh macrophage you see the
elongate miller mineral particles in the
upper left
uh they're being invaginated and taken
into
the macrophage cell where they
activate a number of systems cell
signaling systems
and the release of cytokines that are
associated with inflammation so this is
you know it's a complex system that we
won't go into any great detail on now
but collectively this process is
referred to as the
inflammasome and and so this macrophage
the inflammasome is being activated by
these elongated mineral particles
and it's excreting an interleukin a type
of cytokine interleukin-1 beta
so one of the things that we have done
at nih is look
because we have the ability now using
nanotechnology
to to manufacture um
uh elongate mineral particles of various
sizes and and shapes and and um
and makeup and what we're what we were
interested
here in this experiment is looking at
the relationship between the aspect
ratio which is
ar over in the graph on the right ar
is it so these these particles are very
uniform they all have an aspect ratio of
six to one
and then at the bottom of the graph you
see uh
uh a lesser aspect ratio the message
being here that the large
the larger the aspect ratio
the greater that the uh
inflammasome is activated and what's
interesting about this
experiment is up in the right you can
see that
particles even less than two microns in
length
cause this type of inflammasome
activation
and we think that's very very important
with respect to the present
definitions of regulatory asbestos
so so this is another picture of a
macrophage
and in this case the macrophage has
tried to engulf
elongate mineral particles and it's
become frustrated with that process
so it is it is creating what uh a
a cytochrome cytochrome storm if you
will
and um so uh
the next step in this process would be
for this macropage to recruit other
macrophages and begin
scarring off these these elongate
mineral particles
so uh that is really what is the
initiation of the platform ancient
formation that i showed you on the
previous slide
again these these particles break down
they break down in the environment
these these bundle these bundles of
fibers
break down in the environment they also
interestingly and this is work done by
dr phil cook
at epa's laboratory in duluth duluth
minnesota
what phil cook did was he dosed animals
with
with bundles of various types of
asbestos
and monitored them over the course of of
two years
so what we see here
is that on the on the y-axis the number
of elongate mineral particles actually
went up in the lung over the course of
those two years so he gave
one dose and that dose
actually grew of course across
the course of those two years so we
think this has a lot to do with why
asbestos has it
has a latency period of years in some
cases
because bundles are splitting into
smaller and smaller
uh sizes and uh they're
continuing to cause this uh inflamma
inflammatory reaction in the lung
presently um and this this is a graph
uh cumulative frequency distribution of
the sizes
of particles that we collected in libby
montana
and what we knew after the early stages
of our investigation
was that most of the particles that we
were seeing were less than 5 microns
the red line through this graph
indicates
epa's regulatory limit so epa regulates
everything to the right
but doesn't but does not regulate
anything
to the left based upon the length
of the elongate mineral particle we
think this is problematic
because uh as i showed you on the on the
pre a couple of slides back even fibers
as short as two microns can
activate the inflamma cell
so that brings us um let's see how our
time is doing here that brings us close
to the
to the end of my presentation but i
wanted to remind you
that in fact these arguments are
raging right now i know we're all busy
of course with the
the coronavirus issues and covet 19.
but as as we as we deal with this
the discussions and and
debates uh and science regarding
exposure to these elongate mineral
particles
is raging largely in part
due to exposure to cosmetic products
that have these so-called unregulated
particles in them uh and uh
as you can see baby powder is is
highlighted here
baby johnson johnson baby powder is not
the only product that where
that's problematic but uh it's probably
one of the most controversial right now
so let's see here
so um within the last
several months fda has become interested
in this
in this uh issue as well and these
graphs are public now so i can show show
you them but
what we see here is the same phenomena
where
in fact most of the particles these
taken from various
cosmetic products very recently
have these elongate mineral particles
that are
shorter than the regulated limit again
the regulated
uh limit is five microns if you look at
the x-axis
most of the particles in in these
samples that are being pulled
are shorter than the regulatory limit
yet we know from uh history
and from toxicology and from the
information that i just showed you that
these
that these uh short particles can indeed
cause
uh disease and and death
so we're we're debating that right now
in the in the forensic and um
toxicological arenas
this this study um was done by niosh
a few years ago and it's and it
highlights the same concept
so what was done here is dr les stainer
went back to old epidemiological studies
and pulled the light microscopic slides
from many studies and
measured them using an electron
microscope his objective here is to look
and see what the relationship between
the shorter particles
and the regulated particles were and
you can read his conclusions here but
what you see and again this red line
depicts um everything that is in fact
regulated all of that being you know
toward you toward the viewer
so the the um the white
topped bars are regulated
but again most of the material in these
uh in these studies in these
epidemiological studies that had been
originally
measured with light microscopy when they
were looked at with electron microscopy
they dominated the exposure and um
this is this is this is a problem so um
i think that might be
my last slide yeah there it is so i'm
happy to answer any questions or
or try to do that if i can and thank you
dr weiss for the outstanding
presentation and we will now
move to the q a portion of this
presentation
as a reminder please submit your
questions in the q a box
and any pres questions we cannot answer
today we will answer them via email
so let's take a look at our questions
coming in from our audience members and
we have
time for just a few today our first
question dr weiss
is what was the primary symptoms
that appeared in the exposure
so um what
what we saw in in libby montana
was we we knew there were cases of lung
cancer and mesothelioma
but far and away most of the disease
that we saw
were plural plural plaques plural plural
plaquing
and when we engaged the industry
on this topic and and we knew that this
plural plaquing would progress to lethal
disease if it was allowed to
to proceed and and there's really no
treatment for it so once the plaquing
initiative was initiated it it typically
continued to a debilitating or lethal
uh disease um uh
you know what what we saw was far and
away most of this material
what uh most of the disease was related
to this pleural plaque and not
mesothelioma or lung cancer
thank you for that and were they aware
that the dust in the air
was asbestos at the time
there was discussion about that but uh
the industry you know as you saw from
the video
the industry dominated the the town
they owned they they donated all the
money to the
the high school to to keep the school
going
interestingly they had spread
vermiculite contaminated vermiculite all
over the track and the
the track coach died of mesothelioma uh
they
uh supported the churches they said they
they
for all practical purposes owned the
hospital
uh there were there was some evidence
that
they they had such dominant dominant
influence over the hospital that
diagnoses were changed and that sort of
thing
uh but um
they're the the
um the town was essentially owned by
the the industry and so there were
rumors of
asbestos being present but they had
effectively convinced not just
the population but the regulatory
authorities that this was not asbestos
that it was cleavage fragments
and uh and they fell outside of the
regulatory range
thank you for that and what is the
difference between
asbestos and cleavage product
uh well that's the debate that's going
on right now
in in i'm not a mineralogist
but asbestos uh my my understanding
is that asbestos is uh
born of of a
uh of a process
of a geologic process that pulls
the rock somewhat like taffy it uh
it stretches the rock it becomes very
high in
in tensile strength etc cleavage
fragments by contrast are
chips or crystals that break off
of larger pieces of rock that are of the
same mineral nature so if you have
let's say you have a rock of tremolite
you can have
tremolite that is in fact grown
geologically grown
over millions of years as as an asbesto
form type but you can also
have weaknesses in the crystal structure
that cause
long thin elongate mineral particles and
that's why i use that term
to um to form and and the argument
between industry and the regulators
right now is that cleavage fragments are
not true asbestos
and therefore they cannot be regulated
and that's the case still in our country
and that's why
um uh products you know
such as those that i showed are still
allowed
on the market despite the fact that we
know they're causing disease we know how
the disease is caused
by this inflammatory reaction etc
it's uh it's it's a very interesting
forensic problem
interesting to me because i've been
working on it for more than 20 years and
i'm still working on it
it's still an argument in in the in the
regulatory arena
we have time for one more question and
here's an interesting one
does pay does baby powder contain
these elongated mineral products
yes
short and sweet huh thank you dr weiss
and thank you for this outstanding
presentation once again for your
important research
do you have any closing remarks for our
audience as we close today
no i i but i would like to just thank
uh um the lab lab roots and especially
uh thanks to tyler uh and lynn
and susie you for for guiding me through
this
i apologize for the little glitch that
we had there
uh this uh virtual world is new to all
of us so i'm i'm gonna take a pass on
that
and thanks to everyone who joined joined
today i hope you
you i hope it was instructive and
interesting to you and i'm glad to try
and answer any questions if i can
answer your emails yes
definitely and thank you again dr weiss
um for your presentation and as a final
reminder to our audience members
any questions that were submitted that
were not answered today
will be answered via email by dr weiss
this presentation will be available for
on-demand
viewing until november 2020
so please share it with your colleagues
who may have missed today's
topic thank you again for your
participation until next time
take care and stay healthy bye bye